blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman i want to start with immigration
today because we're continuing to follow
the immigration situation at the u.s
mexico border
you may well know that donald trump's
presidency saw
some horrible things happen from the
standpoint of immigration including the
scaling up of the separation
of immigrant children from their parents
scaling up
of um specific types of deportations
although deportations
were actually quite high under barack
obama no progress whatsoever
on some kind of permanent status for for
daca the
dreamer recipients the list goes on and
on and we've talked about that
and as joe biden's domestic policy
during his first hundred days
has been widely successful empirically
popular
with the american people including even
with many republicans
republicans and right-wing media have
had to come up
with something that will register
as a pseudo scandal for joe biden
and criticisms of him other than simply
he's a socialist
that might resonate with the american
people and one such criticism one such
area
has been immigration despite the almost
painful double standard for us right i
mean you know the right doesn't
understand double standards or they're
not affected by them anymore but
despite what for us has been an almost
painful double standard of
them starting to pretend to care about
the kids at the border
the day that joe biden becomes president
while
they said nothing about it when donald
trump was president of the united states
they have been pushing this crisis at
the border story
and to some degree it has worked the
number of americans who believe
that the immigration situation is a top
issue has almost doubled from june i
think it was about 28
of americans believed it was an
emergency situation in june now 48
percent do
they've also included in this pseudo
scandal
the numbers of increased border
crossings excuse me
during the first part of the year and as
we previously talked about that's very
deceptive because there's a big
seasonality to border crossings in the
first
quarter of the year particularly in
february and march
every year border crossings go up
this year in particular we not only saw
that for seasonal reasons
but there's also been this pent-up
demand from people who would have tried
to cross it sometime in 2020
and they did not because of the pandemic
movement was just dramatically reduced
during the pandemic so
we talked about the the kind of
seasonality of that and why just looking
at that change month to month doesn't
really tell us everything we need to
know
now there's a real new problem for
republicans pushing this
and that's that the number of
unaccompanied migrant children
that are being held in these jail-like
conditions by customs and border patrol
the number is down 84 in the span of
just a month
as of wednesday there were 954 children
remaining in these border patrol
facilities that's down from nearly 6 000
on march 28th that's an incredible
decline
per official speaking to cnn the average
time that kids are now in border patrol
custody is down to 28 hours
it was 133 hours on march 28th
that is nearly an 80 reduction in how
long each of these kids is spending with
border patrol now
this may actually be part of why
you've been hearing less about this from
republicans for the last 10 to 14 days
it's not that they care about the facts
they've
just decided to ignore the topic because
of these numbers and
to be fair they've been distracted with
some other things as well now i'm going
to be consistent
how could i honestly say three minutes
ago
some of this fluctuation is seasonal and
now say
this is down only because of joe biden
no
there is likely some seasonality here as
well
as to why we saw the number of children
decline
in april versus march but part of this
is because joe biden actually made it a
priority to resolve more of these cases
more quickly
and to get the numbers down now the big
picture is that this changes
almost nothing about the urgency of
finding a permanent solution to the
immigration situation
daca needs to be dealt with it's long
overdue there needs to be a permanent
solution for
uh those under the the daca program but
the point here
is that even the acute numbers that
republicans are now
cynically pointing to remember during
the trump administration they didn't
care about these children at the border
the numbers republicans are now
cynically pointing to in order to attack
joe biden
are now looking increasingly better and
better so how will right-wing media
and republicans react there's a few
possibilities part one is they may do
what they've been doing the last 10 to
14 days which is they may just stop
talking about it
reminds me of the ebola situation in
2014
leading up barack obama re-elected in
2012
then we had the campaign for the
midterms of 2014
leading up to the midterms in november
of 2014
it was day after day after day of ebola
ebola ebola obama's handling ebola
terribly remember two people died in the
u.s i think none of those two people
even contracted it in the u.s it was
just hammering on ebola
and i said at the time not an incredibly
uh
astute predict didn't take much skill to
predict
i said this is politically motivated
after the election there's going to be
no more talk of this and
after the midterms there was no more
talk of ebola
contrast that with trump saying no one's
going to talk about
covid if i lose in november and the
election's over and of course
that was not the case because it was a
real problem actually
mishandled by trump in any case that may
be one approach from republicans which
is now that the number of kids at the
border is down 84
just don't talk about it second option
is they may just lie
and talk about it as if the numbers
don't exist or aren't available just
continue
saying the same thing they might go with
unfortunately biden has still left
almost a thousand kids at the border
facilities ignoring
that that number is down 84 percent they
may just be more vague and say there are
still kids being held by joe biden or
something that may be one thing
you may see headlines like biden
administration
continues child detention program
that was initiated by barack obama
that'd be like a beautiful fox news
headline
that ignores what happened in the four
years uh intervening
but truly while knowing that this is
just
one part of the immigration problem it
is really difficult to change anything
quickly when the american federal
government is involved it's a country of
331 million people
that's why the biden vaccination program
has been so notable
that's why reducing these numbers of
kids at the border by 84 percent in a
month
there's a seasonality but it still is an
accomplishment and a legitimate one at
that
we'll see how republicans react to it we
have new polling and it is
it is remarkable it has been 15 years
since americans were as optimistic about
the future of the country as they are
today
two new polls again confirm some things
that we already knew
americans largely approve of joe biden's
performance as president so far
but the polls were also asking about
american optimism more generally
and an abc ipsos poll finds that almost
two-thirds of americans are optimistic
about the next year
americans have not been this optimistic
about the year to come
since 2006 per the same abc
poll a second poll released by yahoo
news and yougov
finds that 57 percent of the country
approves of joe biden's handling of the
pandemic
when asked if biden's performance was
better worse or the same than expected
the plurality 39 said biden's doing even
better than expected
28 percent said worse 24 said about what
we expected
and overall joe biden has a 54 approval
rating now
you and i might see that and say 54.
that's not that's not so good that's not
a very high number
uh remember that donald trump never hit
50
even on a single day of his presidency
and was plagued by approval
in the uh 30s for the most part and even
29
when he left office so this this is a
change for sure
now in terms of the country being
divided
this is this is interesting and not
great numbers for joe biden
um 28 of americans believe that the
country
is more divided since joe biden took
office
23 percent believe it is
i'm sorry 23 say more divided 28
say less divided um that is
interesting because everybody's blaming
biden
the people that think the country is
more united think it's more united
because of joe biden the people that
think the country is more divided
also think it's more divided because of
joe biden but
what's clear is that overall politics
has become a lot more boring
and people seem to be okay with that now
fascinatingly
there was the assumption that because
things would be boring under joe biden
shows like the david pakman show
wouldn't do well in fact there were
gleeful trump is saying
david when trump is gone your show will
be circling the drain which is a phrase
we've been hearing for 15 years
we keep growing but put that aside for a
second i assumed
we would we would see a decline in
viewership corporate media has seen a
big decline in viewership since trump
has left
but then something i really don't
understand happened because i was
prepared for like a full year of really
things being pretty slow
in late march then early april mid april
april just finished the numbers came
that back very strongly
there were no biden scandals nothing in
the biden administration even coming
close to the insanity of the trump white
house
and yet that dip we saw that we see
after every election
in january and february and early march
it's almost completely recovered we were
back up to 30 million views
in april uh 12 million views on facebook
these are like 2020 numbers once again
so i'm curious what you think is going
on
because things are kind of boring in a
sort of uh salacious
uh from a salacious evaluation type
standpoint
tv networks are reporting significantly
lower ratings trump no doubt was good
for ratings and yet
we're almost back to where we were in
december which was a record month
not all the way maybe 85 percent of the
way there if you look at
what did best in april there's some
trump stuff in there
that's left over that he's still doing
things but it's a lot of other things
clips about uh right wingers who just
call into the show to talk to me did
really well the matt gates scandal got a
lot of attention
critiques of right-wing media framing
did well um
reporting on some of these uh corporate
scams foxconn
and others coverage of the derek chauvin
trial stories about vaccine conspiracies
and other things
at this point there's like seven or
eight different general areas of content
that are doing very well so something is
going on it's not only that people are
more optimistic than they've been for 15
years they're optimistic but they're
also not
tuning out if it bleeds it leads you
know we know about that
if people are satisfied and complacent
rather than panicked
they tend to watch a lot less news but
yet people are watching almost as much
of the show as they were in december
the most in optimistic interpretation i
have
is people recognize that things are
going in the right direction
but realize that if we tune out now and
not pay attention to what's going on
maybe we get trump or something like him
back
in 2024. the real explanation could be
anything i'd be curious to hear from
from you why is most of that election
peak audience
already back let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter
deepakman very interested in hearing
from you
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription when you
go
to blinkist.com david pakman i've put
the link
right underneath this video the david
pakman show is of course
dependent on individual supporters from
the audience whether you watch on
youtube
listen to the podcast watch us on free
speech tv
you can grab a membership at
joinpakman.com it's cheap it's quick
it's easy and we do a daily
extra show for our members
sign up at joinpakman.com okay something
completely
predictable is happening with so-called
vaccine passports so-called mandatory
vaccines
and this we predicted it weeks ago it
didn't
require any special insights i didn't
need a crystal ball
i'm not some kind of soothsayer for
realizing this was going to happen
on the one hand we expected there would
be
schools businesses employers
airlines whatever that would start to
say
after a certain date if you want to do
business with us
if you want to go to school here etc you
will need to be vaccinated against covet
19. now that was our prediction at the
time it hadn't yet started to happen
we also were seeing some states arizona
was one that we mentioned at the time
but now there are more
that were decreeing bans
against mandatory vaccination or
so-called vaccine passport so for
example we covered last week or the week
before
that arizona governor doug ducey
defiantly said
we will not have any vaccine passports
here mandatory vaccine requirements but
of course
it only applies to state government and
to municipalities
tucson can't require every tucson
resident get vaccinated but of course
that was never going to happen however
we are seeing
more and more some employers but many
many schools we now have more than 100
u.s colleges and universities that are
saying to come back to campus in the
fall
you need to be vaccinated against
coronavirus there's nothing legally
complicated about it
before the pandemic when i went to
college i had to show proof of certain
vaccinations i don't remember exactly
hepatitis and
i needed a you know a tetanus shot
booster whatever there's been a list
this has been going on for a very long
time
and exactly what we predicted is
happening and what is that
that people in some of these states
because now you have in addition to
arizona you have the arkansas governor
signing into law
measures preventing governments from
requiring vaccination but this is not
about governments requiring it
um texas south dakota idaho you know all
these florida all these different states
are signing different things
banning required vaccination but it only
applies to government and some
very narrow other situations so you are
starting to see
the posts are all over the internet
they're all over my twitter every time i
tweet about vaccines they're all in the
comments every time you read about
oh uh this university will require
vaccination that one will for on-campus
students people commenting and saying
this is illegal the governor already
banned it
this was written on the wall go back to
my commentary from when we talked about
arizona issuing a ban on vaccine
requirements
and i said you were going to have these
anti-vaxxed people showing up
saying you can't do this because the
governor banned it and of course the
governor's orders
do not apply to colleges and
universities and you know ticketmaster
and live nation
or if the phoenix suns in arizona their
ba the basketball team wants to say to
come to games
you have to have proof of vaccination or
they might say you need proof of
vaccination or you've got to take a
negative test
if you're not vaccinated these are two
different things and we knew that they
were going to start confusing them
either deliberately
or be because they don't actually
understand
the limits of what government can and
cannot decree here one
thing has nothing to do with the other
it was predictable that it would create
chaos and we're not even at the point
where kids are starting to go back to
school yet
by the time that fall comes we hopefully
will be
closer to herd immunity there are
concerns as to whether we will ever get
there but
we will we should be closer if not
actually there i think we will be doing
very well as far as cases and deaths go
by that point in time
everybody who wants a vaccine by far
will have been able to get one we're
getting
close to that and now it's about
convincing people to want to get the
vaccine
way more colleges and universities and
maybe airlines and maybe other venues
and businesses and on and on
hospitals whatever will have said in
order to work here
in order to attend school here in order
to patronize our services that we offer
you will need to have proof of
vaccination and they are going to be
going absolutely nuts how does this get
solved i have no idea
i have no idea the the level of
misunderstanding
and it's predictable listen it's true
that
even people who aren't particularly
ignorant if you don't follow this stuff
closely and you hear
you know arizona arizona governor bans
mandatory vaccines
and meanwhile arizona state university
says you've got to be vaccinated to come
to campus
that does sound like a conflict in some
sense and it requires
understanding that what the arizona
governor passed
applies only to a city can't require
being vaccinated to go to the dmv or
deny you dmv services
that type of thing it does not apply to
arizona arizona state university or
whatever else
um it was completely predictable it's
going to be absolute chaos and i think
there is going to be
probably as travel starts to open in
other countries there are already other
countries that are leaning in the
direction of saying
if american travelers if any travelers
want to come here you will need to be
vaccinated this is likely to reach a
fever pitch in july
into august and as we get close to the
fall semester there's going to be
protests there's going to be absolute
and total chaos and it was completely
predictable all along if you thought
things were already
bad for beleaguered republican
congressman matt gates
they are getting a hell of a lot worse
and the pressure is truly building on
the republican party to do
something about his continued presence
in the house of representatives
here's the story joel greenberg who's a
major player
in this investigation that looks at
whether matt gates committed
all sorts of different crimes including
possibly trafficking underage girls joel
greenberg wrote in a letter
that has been obtained by the daily
beast that he and matt gates paid for
sex with multiple women
including a minor girl 17 years of age
at the time in question
the letter was drafted after greenberg
asked roger
stone a close ally of trump remember
for help obtaining a pardon greenberg
wanted
stone to help him get a pardon from
donald trump at the very end of donald
trump's term
greenberg wrote in the letter quote on
more than one occasion
this individual was involved in sexual
activity
with several of the other girls the
congressman
from florida's first congressional
district and myself
from time to time gas money or gifts
rent or partial tuition payments were
made to several of these girls
including the individual who was not yet
18 years old i did see the acts occur
first hand this is a first-hand witness
and venmo
transactions cash app or other payments
were made to these girls
on behalf of the congressman this is
a bombshell blockbuster alleged
first-hand claim
now understand that for some time now
we've suspected that this specific
allegation was going to come out
why well when we learned that this joel
greenberg decided to cooperate with
investigators
greenberg's lawyer fritz sheller held a
hilarious
press briefing right outside a
courthouse and was asked straight up did
your client joel greenberg introduce
matt gates to underage girls check out
the then
hilarious but ominous response from
greenberg's lawyer fritz sheller
did your client introduce nat gates to
any underage girls
or secularly
all right so i'm just going to let you
sit down there
and so i can look over your head and
ignore that question
i apologize i i just can't answer that
question i wasn't okay
that was that was a little devious
you're hiding down there below and
you zing that at me you know so
okay so anybody who sees that is
immediately thinking
that really sounds like something we
should be looking into that's the
furthest thing from a no that i could
imagine and indeed now this letter
obtained by the daily beast
written by joel greenberg allegedly says
exactly that matt gates and i paid women
for sex
one of those women i know was a child
was an underage girl
17 years old now for me this is not
really about prostitution
there's an important and prescient
conversation to have
about sex work and whether there should
be legalization decriminalization
regulation of sex work for the safety of
the service providers
this is a big topic it's a bigger topic
than this particular story
this story is about the constant
self-incrimination of matt gates
possibly statutory rape and or
trafficking of a minor if indeed one of
the girls he met
he paid to have travel across state
lines and of course
the incredible double standard between
matt gates membership and the supposed
party of family values
the republican party and this behavior
in conjunction with
many republicans continuing to defend
him now that being said
the number of republicans coming to matt
gates defense that number is shrinking
in number
uh almost daily now much of this is
being denied for now
a spokesperson for matt gates said to
cnn congressman
gates has never paid for sex nor has he
had sex with a 17 year old as an adult
we'll see one of the even crazier parts
is roger stone's involvement that's not
it's almost like a detail but it's
actually crazy
in a series of messages that were
exchanged over the encrypted messaging
app
signal that the daily beast obtained
greenberg wrote to stone
if i get you 250 000 in bitcoin would
that help or
is this not a financial matter and roger
stone replied
i understand all of this and have taken
it into consideration
i will know more in the next 24 hours i
cannot push
too hard because of the nonsense
surrounding pardons
and then stone later wrote to greenberg
i hope you are prepared to wire me
250 000 because i am feeling confident
presumably in being able to get
greenberg a pardon
the pardon did not happen so this story
does not appear to be going away anytime
soon
it seems to be getting worse and worse
for matt gates i think gates has
benefited hugely
in a sense gates has benefited from joe
biden getting so many things done
that the right-wing media attention and
media attention in general
has been on a lot of right-wingers
trying to find any way to attack joe
biden and it's pulled attention away
from matt gates
i expect the tension to get back to matt
gates maybe this week maybe next week
and i don't expect things to go
particularly well for him we'll have
more coverage of this
on our instagram page follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
we have much more coming up today
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well
as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
so republican senator mitt romney was
brutally booed
and according to people in the room
called a traitor
by republicans at the utah state
republican convention this weekend you
have to hear this
and this we're kind of on a search for
answers to a very seemingly simple
question that question is
whether the republican party is the
party of donald trump is it still the
party of donald trump or
will the republican party go back to
being the party of someone like
mitt romney people like romney john
mccain and the like
one data point has been the really
consistent polling where the vast
majority of the republican electorate
still says
we like trump we believe trump won in
2020. we would vote for trump again we
want trump to remain involved in
politics
that's one data point utah held its
republican convention this weekend
and there was not only an attempt to
censure mitt romney
by republicans which almost passed more
on that in a second
romney was extensively booed by his own
fellow republicans interrupting his
speech multiple times
take a look at this video take a listen
to this audio
[Applause]
so what do you think about president
biden's first hundred days
now you know me as a person who who says
what he thinks and i don't hide the fact
that i wasn't a fan of our last
president's character issues
and i'm also
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
aren't you embarrassed
and i'm also no fan of the yeah that
that is really something else
you know in the relatively anti-trump
republican state of utah
utah is not i don't know what's the
state where i mean like uh
south carolina republicans like trump
much more
than utah republicans like trump um
and even in the relatively
anti-republican trump state of utah
romney is still booed relentlessly
and those very republicans pushed a
motion to censure mitt romney
because he had the audacity to think for
himself in the trump impeachment trials
and vote to convict on some of those
counts so they held the vote to
censure romney it failed but barely
798-711 really close vote
given that these are supposedly
anti-trump republicans
romney reportedly left the venue almost
immediately
after finishing his speech and of course
the real question here is what does this
mean for the future of the republican
party
i don't know that it's totally obvious
that rejecting the romney wing
is necessarily bad for the republican
party what i mean by that is
trump individually completely backfired
for republicans
trump got elected in 2016. republicans
lost the house in 2018.
republicans lost the senate in 2020
republicans lost the white house
in 2020. but trumpism and by that i mean
no policy you just fight cultural
battles you oppose the libs
you try to anger people on the left that
may have more staying power
as an approach if people other than
trump are the ones pushing it we just
don't have an answer yet 2022 will be a
partial answer
do people in the romney wing get removed
in 2022
and do people in the trumpian wing
like lauren beaubert madison taylor
greene madison cawthorne
get re-elected notice that mitt romney's
views have not really changed much
since 2012 when he was the republican
nominee
most of the people in that room who are
booing him now
if they were old enough to vote in 2012
voted for mitt romney
this is more a sign of how off the deep
end
the republican electorate is it's
similar actually
to remember the situation with the late
senator john mccain
john mccain was a very popular arizona
republican senator
was the republican presidential nominee
in 2008 lost to barack obama
they chose him to be their nominee in
2008. all of them
almost all of them voted for mccain in
the general election
and then just eight years later in 2016
when trump starts with i prefer war
heroes who didn't get captured and
uh trump ridicules mccain's military
service a lot of those same republicans
were cheering
when donald trump went after mccain in
2016. now
it is true that sarah palin mccain's
vice presidential running mate in 2008
was a sort of proto-trumpian figure
but regardless consider the trajectory
these
same republican voters are now calling
one of their previous nominees a
communist in mitt romney
that all being said trump activated new
people
who never participated in politics
before so some of the booze you're
hearing
are presumably people who simply weren't
engaged at all in 2008 and 2012 but many
were
and now they've decided the people we
thought were the good choices in 2008
and 2012
now we boo them now we call them
communists now we call them traitors
the same republicans who do not care at
all about policy
but are about how bad cancel culture is
now we're loudly trying to cancel
any republican who's even mildly normal
and that's
the way i would describe mitt romney
cautiously i would say he's mildly
normal
2022 is going to be wild and it's going
to be really significant
in terms of the future of the republican
party and we're going to be watching it
uh i don't really know whether what i'm
going to show you
next is hilariously unhinged
or sort of sad in a way nearly six
months to the day
after losing the november 2020 election
to joe biden
and really losing by quite a bit it
wasn't close donald trump
has appeared at his mar-a-lago club in
florida
to sort of send himself and his club
members off for the summer trump
apparently is going to be relocating to
his new jersey golf club for the summer
mar-a-lago closes soon after memorial
day i guess because it just gets too hot
and muggy in florida
and trump will head to jersey and the
goal as far as we know is to build some
kind of a political operation
there and donald trump is supposed to
just speak to his club members and say
thank you have a great summer he ends up
ranting about the supposedly rigged
election claims they're looking at vote
counts from all sorts of states they're
not nothing is happening anywhere of
course
joe biden has been president now for
months and even the crowd
seems unable to get into it you hear
like an occasional cheer
but some aspect of this is really sad
take a look at it and then let's discuss
let's see what they find i wouldn't be
surprised if they found
thousands and thousands and thousands of
votes so we're going to watch that very
closely and
after that you'll watch pennsylvania and
you watch georgia
and you're going to watch michigan and
wisconsin
and you're watching new hampshire they
found a lot of votes up in new hampshire
just now you saw that
because this was a rigged election
everybody knows it and
we're going to be uh we're going to be
watching it very closely but
start off by you just take a look it's
on
it's on closed circuit i guess it's all
over the place because everyone's
talking about yesterday front page of
the new york times they didn't want to
write it
but that's because they thought they
were going to have a negative decision
that the judge gave him
gave us a positive decision so is this
depressing or is it funny
this was once the president of the
united states he messed up
everything he failed miserably on the
pandemic
he lost an election as well as losing
the house in 2018
losing the senate for his party in 2020
losing the white house in 2020
he's now living at a golf club i'm
imagining him going to the buffet
uh and just ranting to anyone who will
listen to him
about how it was all supposedly rigged
should we be mad
should we pity trump what's the correct
emotion here one of the things i am
starting to think
though is that donald trump might
genuinely believe he won in november
this is something we've been wondering
for a while
trump has of course been grifting around
the election for a long time
i think donald trump realized early on
in the fiasco
he wasn't going to be president for four
more years as like a practical reality
but he realized he could keep scamming
his followers by raising money
by claiming i'm gonna fight with your
money uh even though he knew he was
never going to win but the question was
does he really believe he won
all along in watching trump still rant
about this six months later
he seems to lie uncontrollably but to
believe the lies himself and what i mean
by that is when trump says oh they're
finding votes in new hampshire
we're looking at that closely we're
looking at this closely
i'm leaning more and more towards trump
may actually believe that
so there's this debate did donald trump
know he lost or did he think he won i
think it's actually both
i think trump knew he lost in the
practical sense that he was not going to
get four more years
but i believe trump truly believes at
this point that it was stolen from him
and that he is the rightful winner that
joe biden did not legitimately win
so trump both knew he wouldn't be
president
and he was scamming his supporters in
that sense
but by this time by friday at mar-a-lago
he's no longer grifting he has convinced
himself that he actually did win he is
now living in a world of fantasy not
unlike what he's lived in for a long
time even as a real estate business guy
or as a reality tv show host and i do
i mean i admit i get some pleasure out
of seeing that
this is now donald trump's existence but
with most of the 75 million people who
voted for him
still wanting him to be president if we
don't take this seriously
he's now going to jersey to be close to
new york and mount a political operation
he
has every intention of playing king
maker in 2022
if we don't deal with this in a serious
way
he could again be president without a
doubt and many of his acolyte
suck-ups could get re-elected in 2022
many new trump suck-ups trumpian elected
officials
could get elected in 2022. now one other
thing a few people were posting this
video to twitter twitter
saying this must be from months ago like
trump isn't still doing this in may or
it was the last day of april when this
was actually filmed
i had the same reaction i thought this
must be an old video
like when trump first went to mar-a-lago
in january
uh but no this this is new video of
trump
this past friday talking about how it
was rigged
and we're looking at vote totals very
strongly nothing's going on it's done
and i believe at this point trump really
does believe it
really does believe that he won i don't
think it's just a grift at this point in
time
let me know your thoughts about that at
this point does donald trump
really believe he won the november 2020
election
let me know we'll follow up the david
pakman show depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him
this is really one of the most
remarkable confrontations of a
republican delusion that i've seen in a
long time
and it took place on fox news no doubt
a fox news host neil cavuto asked
former republican senator kelly lefler
remember her
really the perfect question about her
claims
that there were problems and
irregularities
in the 2020 election in georgia in which
she was a candidate and lost to rafael
warnock and the question is really
simple if there were problems
with the trump versus biden results and
they can't be trusted
because the georgia secretary of state
brad raffensberger was a partisan and
biased arbiter of that election
he supported you kelly leffler in that
race
what does that mean isn't that an
obvious conflict now
remember that i brought this up a
similar version of this back in november
just after the election when i tweeted
quote
why have trump and republicans accepted
the results
from house and senate elections but not
presidential
everything was on the same ballots in
other words tons of republicans
who won in the house and senate on the
same ballots as where trump lost
were saying we cannot trust these
results it's rigged
this there's all sorts of irregularities
but so hold on
we also can't trust that you won right
and of course that's not what they were
talking about an
obvious uh problem with their argument
so let's now get to the video of neil
cavuto
who reduces kelly leffler to mumbling
and stumbling by pointing out you know
the guy
you're saying needs to be investigated
for his role in the election
he supported you in that race and of
course part of the implication here
is maybe he did something screwy to help
you as well
right take a look at this just a
remarkable
60 seconds of footage making sure that
everyone's voice is heard
all right so if we have an investigation
into that it would be investigations
after other investigations this one more
focused i guess on the behavior of mr
referenceburger but
um you would charge that you want to
probe into whether he used his office to
advance his political interest he was
supporting you
and and and your your colleague so
how was that opposite what
your interests were you were both on the
same page
that's not exactly correct i mean look
he's our top elections official he's not
a partisan official per se but my focus
is
he wasn't for you but he wasn't for your
opponent right senator he was for you
he was first under purdue what would be
in his interest to sabotage that
not not suggesting sabotage i'm
suggesting that
georgians don't trust voting right now
and he took actions that led to a lack
of confidence
wow well if brad raffensberger
took actions that led to a lack of
confidence
and he supported kelly leffler we should
be looking into whether kelly lefler
really only lost by a little bit to
rafael warnock maybe kelly lefler lost
by a lot
but brad raffensberger in the same way
that he maybe pulled funny business
against trump
because he didn't like trump this is
their story
maybe he pulled some funny business in
favor of david perdue and kelly lefler
who he supported now of course what's
the truth here
the truth is i think kelly leffler knows
the georgia election was pretty fair
uh trump simply lost she has sort of
played coy with all of this stuff
because remember that there was that
period between november and january
where kelly lefler and david perdue were
campaigning for those special elections
she was fighting for her political life
between november and january 5th which
was the day of that special election
and during that time she needed donald
trump's support
at least she believed she needed it i
don't know maybe it hurt more than it
helped
so she was playing coy with the election
fraud stuff when she was
asked uh directly whether she agreed
with donald trump that the election in
georgia was rigged i think during the
debate with rafael warnock it came up
she would say stuff like well we need to
investigate
the president has every right to demand
this and that
uh to his satisfaction that this was
done correctly and that was done
correctly we need to ensure
every vote every legal vote is counted
and every voice is heard
she was playing coy with it to avoid
having to say
no i think trump's telling you bs but
then that risks losing the trump support
she thought she needed in that
special election in january i believe
she doesn't care about trump
i think she cares about herself i think
kelly lefler probably recognizes that
trump's a disaster but if trump is
useful to her if it helps her win
then she'll say whatever and accept
donald trump's support she might want to
run again
and she's probably looking at the same
polls we're looking at which show
that at least for right now donald trump
is a player in republican politics
she might need trump's help if she wants
to run again
and she's going to keep playing coy and
continuing to be unable to just answer
simple questions or enable
refusing to uh questions like this one
which is
you know the guy you're saying we need
to investigate
supported you in 2020. so where does
that leave us
with any of this nonsense i was hoping
that the last we'd see of kelly leffler
was when she lost to rafael warnock in
january
appears not to be the case and she is
truly
detestable and so horrible for the
country
and seems as determined as ever to get
involved again and to do more damage you
almost get the sense
that kelly leffler is like surprised
she's being asked this question on fox
which i mean listen it's sort of
surprising but occasionally neil cavuto
will ask what we would call a real
question
that in other countries just every
interview would have real questions like
this
and she's asked a so-called real
question
and she's unable to string together
anything approximating a coherent
response because
her position on this is and has been
incoherent
incoherent like trump she may run again
and we will need to fight her if that's
indeed what happens
so this is very interesting we have
resolution
in some sense to one of the many
election lie
related lawsuits that are taking place
it's important to follow these stories
to their conclusions newsmax is one of
the right-wing
media networks that was spreading known
demonstrable debunkable lies about the
2020 election in the months after the
november election
one of the targets of these lies was
dominion
voting systems which attracted the
ire of fox news newsmax
rudy giuliani sydney powell the my
pillow guy many people going bonkers
about
dominion voting systems supposed role in
helping to steal the election for donald
trump from donald trump for joe biden
newsmax
specifically made such claims as eric
coomer an executive at dominion was
supposedly part of an
antifa conference call to rig the
election
there were also other claims about
exactly how dominion voting systems
stole
votes from trump and gave them to biden
there's no evidence for any of this
stuff there never was
so dominion voting systems decided to
sort of try to throw the book at these
people sued newsmax
among others and the newsmax lawsuit has
now been settled
this is the first such settlement we
don't know the financial
terms of the settlement but presumably
there is a financial payoff here by
newsmax
and of course we are led to believe
that uh this is only the first of many
but this is just the best tale between
the legs outcome
newsmax has published an apology now the
apology is sort of
bs but it's still interesting to look at
first of all they published it with the
completely anodyne title statement about
dr eric
coomer director of product strategy and
security at dominion voting systems okay
so let's look at this this is the the
retraction and apology
newsmax says since election day various
guest attorneys and hosts on use max
have offered opinions and claims about
dr eric coomer
newsmax would like to clarify its
coverage of dr coomer
and note that while newsmax initially
covered claims by president trump's
lawyers
supporters and others that dr coomer
played a role in manipulating
manipulating dominion voting machines
dominion voting software
and the final vote counts in the 2020
election newsmax
subsequently found no evidence that such
allegations were true
so already they're framing it as we were
bystanders here we did nothing there
were people who came on and made claims
when we looked into the truth of the
claims
we found no evidence for them now this
is a very
uh a sort of cynical view
on the role of newsmax they knew from
day one that there was no evidence but
they continued to allow the claims to be
made
so you know even the framing of the
apologies is pretty much bs
newsmax going on to say many of the
states whose results were contested by
the trump campaign
have conducted recounts and audits and
each state certified the results as
legal and final
there are several facts our viewers
should be aware of this is great
newsmax has found no evidence that dr
coomer interfered with dominion voting
machines or voting software in any way
nor that dr coomer ever claimed to have
done so nor has newsmax found any
evidence that dr coomer ever
participated in any conversation with
members of antifa
nor that he was directly involved with
any partisan political organization
on behalf of newsmax we would like to
apologize for any harm our reporting of
the allegations against coomer
may have cause to dr kumar and his
family for more go to our website and
read facts about dominion
now i love that they did this
but this is one of the most bs apologies
and retractions i've seen because
i mean listen first of all in general
with these apologies and retractions
they did months of the coverage and now
almost no one is going to hear
or value this apology which is
so narrow in scope understand that
they're not even retracting
general claims made about dominion all
they are saying is
the specific claims guests made
about dr coomer's role
are without evidence a lot of the claims
were more broad about dominion voting
systems
as an as an entity as an organization
they're not even retracting or
apologizing about that
never mind all of this other stuff
claims from sydney powell and mike
pillow about venezuela hugo chavez
whatever okay so listen
uh presumably newsmax decided to settle
to avoid going forward because it would
cost them a lot more money
there's a risk for dominion also if the
lawsuit were to move forward and go to
court
maybe dominion doesn't win the
defamation suit
who knows both parties decided it was in
their interest to settle
but i received some emails from people
saying you know the apology
is so narrow and such bs that no one
will see
it might be more impactful if one of
these lawsuits
really led to the complete and total
demise of an
organization like newsmax i can see both
sides because there are risks to going
to trial
i'm sure both sides accounted for those
risks and making their decision to
settle now in terms of what newsmax
really believes
as an entity it is obvious newsmax
never believe this stuff ever ever ever
they are
there there are people taking the
position that newsmax is saying this now
only because they have to but they still
believe the election was stolen no no
no maybe there are some hosts
individually that believe the election
was stolen
i think the reality is newsmax as an
entity
never believed this they were going with
it and allowing guests to push it
for clicks that's all it was i don't
think there was any point at which
newsmax had an editorial position that
this election was stolen by joe biden
this is now one settlement we will see
what more comes of it there are many
more of these in play
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
is a call from dr ryan i don't know why
he's asking me about this he's the
doctor but
it's a question about masks take a
listen
hey dave it is dr ryan i had a question
do you think
that math will become a seasonal thing
and and basically a permanent feature of
society and here's kind of the context
for the question
okay so because you know conservatives
have pushed back against
they're pushing back against vaccines it
seems like we may not reach
full herd affinity and the virus can
continue
to mutate and it's just going to be
harder hard to control
and it becomes like the seasonal flu
that just keeps coming back
and now we have data saying that the
mass itself it seems likely
in my mind that stores would turn on a
masks required sign in you know peaks
season peak
coveted season if it's gonna be
something that's coming around every
year
i think that there is a real chance that
in
some parts of the country mask wearing
becomes uh seasonal and you know the
there's a very uh kind of ominous
article in the new york times that's
spreading about we
we may never reach herd immunity i i
think in practical terms
for this as a pandemic virus we will
reach herd immunity
i do think this could become and it's
not me i mean epidemiologists say this
could become sort of an endemic seasonal
thing
you might get a booster vaccine booster
once a year every couple years
uh like for the flu um but i think that
i'm less sure about uh stores
saying oh during flu season you will
need masks to come in maybe
i think more likely as a first step you
will just see
people in high risk groups that during
flu season
which seems to correlate with when you
might see seasonal
covet as well high-risk people might
just start wearing masks
i know people now who
used to kind of be aware of flu season
as a time when they were at higher risk
but they didn't really behave
differently
who now are saying i think during flu
season i'll wear a mask to the grocery
store
between what is it october and i don't
you know whatever flu season is there's
a few month period there
um i'm just going to wear a mask and i
think that
before we see stores go to some sort of
seasonal mask
thing we will just observe society
and see if there are people who uh
either socialize less during flu season
or where wear masks when they go out i
think it's completely plausible
and the other thing i've said is there's
going to be a long-term psychological
impact of this pandemic
there are people who i mean listen there
are states now
where the coronavirus risk based on the
percentage vaccinated
is down to flu risk in the sense of
there are some states that
in the typical flu season have five
deaths a year that now we're down to ten
coved
i'm sorry five deaths a day over the
course of the year
from flu that are now down to ten deaths
a day from covet
and as vaccination continues you are
going to see covet deaths get down to
the single digits same numbers as flu
that is not likely to feel the same as
before all of this stuff started and
what i mean by that is there are people
who are have realized thanks to this
pandemic
that they were maybe accepting more risk
before during flu season than they're
comfortable going back to
i think there's no doubt about that i
think there will also be ptsd problems
agoraphobia people who just don't want
to be out there they're just feeling i'm
safe at home i think i'll just stay home
even if things get better outside i
think there's going to be a lot of
psychological aspects to this
uh but i do think that dr dr ryan
is uh certainly on to something there
about the future of
masks and that would not the the us
would not be unique in that there are
lots of countries
where during flu season you see masks
worn just as a matter of
a matter of protocol i guess we would
call it we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today
republican senator tim scott is claiming
that congress is
close to a police reform deal is it true
and what would it look like also on the
bonus show
north korea is back and they are warning
the united states over joe biden's big
blunder do they need food aid do they
need medical aid because of the pandemic
typically there's this cycle and that's
when we hear from north korea
and we are going to talk about maybe the
best
argument for increasing the size
not physically but the number of members
in the house of representatives
the the size of the house chamber i
don't really care about it seems plenty
big
but the argument about the size of the
legislative body
what is that argument i will tell you
today on the bonus show we'll discuss
whether you think it's valid
and producer pat getting his second
vaccine dose today
how is he feeling how is he feeling we
will find out in mere moments on the
bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com coupon code
available if you want a discount it's
better21
we'll see you on today's bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman